Her low freak bitches.
Well,
it's like we were talking
about virtual reality.
We're like,
how long before they made a porn,
I mean when the moment
they came up with Oculus,
we knew like it's a matter of time,
matter of time,
and they did it and they did it.
Oh,
it is going to create some
fucking hilarious earthquakes
and a lot of different
relationships and marriages because
people are going to have to uh,
define whether or not fucking a
Hologram is a form of infidelity.
Like you're going to have
to make a rule for that in,
in your relationship.
Is it okay to fuck a Hologram?
Not Alive,
not a person,
but looks like it's fucking you
looking you right in the eyes,
right in the fucking eyes.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Yeah.
It's pretty weird because your brain,
when a Hologram is looking at
you in the eyes in a loving way,
your brain doesn't reject it.
It's like,
oh wow.
I think this girl really likes me.
Oh wait,
it's a hologram.
But in one millisecond you get this
feeling of like strange connection,
which is a,
and again,
we're in the most rudimentary parts of Vr,
only apparently only,
I just read this,
it might've been a dated article,
but only 100,000 people
or so on and HTC vive,
if that's drastically off you guys.
I'm sorry,
but not a lot of people
have VR goggles right now.
So not a lot of people.
And there's a lot of us who are fucking
ear beating people at parties who
clearly just don't want to hear about
it anymore than you want to hear about
someone talking about it dream.
But there's a huge group of people right
now that are having some of the most
psychedelic mind bending
experience is through technology.
And they can't even talk about it or
describe it to people because when you
describe it,
it's like you're talking about a dream,
but you're like,
no,
this is happening to
a lot of us right now.
We're going into alternate dimensions
via technology and hanging out there,
enjoying it,
experiencing the freedom,
uh,
from the confines of being constantly
in an infinitely located in whatever
physical space your body happens to be
inhabiting to suddenly remove that weight
and how I can pop these things on and
instantly translocate to some art universe
that some geniuses created.
Fuck around.
Shoot Arrows,
wander through Minecraft,
have sex with two,
uh,
girls who I always apparently going to
throw out of my house if they didn't fuck
me.
That's what the porn is.
I have
never do that.
But in this universe,
I guess that's what I do.
Yeah.
So the kind of rapey what
is not rapey it's just like,
please,
I don't have money for the rent.
Can I suck your Dick?
Oh,
you know,
it's her idea.
Oh yeah.
You're not saying you're not raping her.
It's not like,
look,
you gotta you gotta give
up some pussy otherwise,
otherwise I'm kicking you in the street.
You could say it if you want.
And to the porn.
I mean,
you could say whatever you want.
Wait a minute.
You have a microphone?
Yeah,
I'm a microphone,
but you can talk to it if
you want to be a Weirdo.
Is there,
but,
okay.
How long before you can talk to it,
how long before it talks back to you?
Well that's,
you're going to look,
you're looking at like a,
so we got to figure out a way to either,
I mean I imagine that probably exists
in some rudimentary way for some kind of
CGI style porn,
but to be able to like instantaneously
communicate with live video porn,
you're going to need some kind of AI
that I don't think we probably have just
yet or we are probably on the PR,
but yes,
that will happen.
Oh,
that's definitely gonna happen.
I've watched x Mckenna again
on the plane the other day.
I watched it for the second time.
That's cool.
It's just as good.
The second time.
That movie freaks me out,
man.
Why?
Because the girl's so
beautiful and she's so,
she's so attractive.
Like you,
you know that guy.
You could see as much as he
knew that she was a robot.
As much as he knew that
he wasn't a robot as much,
as much as he knew that
she was artificial,
he was in love with her and she was
amazing and it seemed like she cared about
him and when she was
talking to him for real,
like when the lights went
out and the camera was down,
spoiler alert,
and she was like,
don't trust him.
I'm like,
this is like a real person.
It's a real person.
She's thinking like a person.
It's a person and he's like completely
locked into this idea that it's a person.
He's hitting a time.
It's a person.
I mean I don't,
this whole distinction between artificial
intelligence and intelligence is the
same as the distinction between
virtual reality and reality.
It's just like another human attempt
to be in control of something.
You want to,
you want to say,
Oh,
I'll tell you if this is
fucking reality or not.
Oh,
this is virtual reality.
This isn't reality reality.
But it's like,
oh really?
So realities compartmentalized
into places where there's,
if something is created by a human,
oh no,
that's not real reality.
Even though humans are reality.
Reality is reality.
Intelligence is intelligence because
the intelligence is inhabiting something
that isn't the human vessel.
It goes back to what we
were talking about earlier,
what,
because it's not in a fucking meat
body now it's artificial intelligence.
How is why intelligence is intelligence,
but here's my weirdness about all this.
You know we were talking about language
and the limitations of language and the
eventuality of a virtual reality and I
wonder how we're going to digest data and
information in a virtual world.
Like if people decide like what if you
decide that you want to read books in a
virtual world,
this is how you want to read books.
The way you want to read books is
what your feet up on the couch in your
mansion,
in your virtual world.
All these girls around you like finger
banging themselves with a high heels on
and Queens fat bottom girls,
you make a rock in the world,
go round plays in the background share,
and you get to sit down and
read books in a virtual world.
What happens then?
Like what?
What happens when you're watching
movies in a virtual world?
Well then that's probably,
that'd be stupid.
I think the movies would be,
they would exist.
I think movies in a virtual world,
they're definitely coming.
Right?
And they're going to,
you're going to exist in the world.
Like you're not gonna sit
down and watch a movie.
Oh No.
They have a great theory theaters
in Vr now you can sit down,
put on a movie and watch it on the,
unlike a massive screen
in VR there I went to,
don't you think,
why do they do that as their limitations
in the medium where they can't have it?
Uh,
the movie play out in front of you.
Like if you went to see jaws,
right?
Oh,
I know.
It's kind of Nice to watch
a movie floating in space.
I don't mind that the virtue of you,
there's an app called virtual
desktop where you like,
you put on your VR goggles and suddenly
your desktop is wrapped around you,
a giant screen,
giant screen wrapped around you that you
then can like pull up any kind of movie
you might want to watch.
And so you just like can
sit in there and why.
And if you look down,
you see space.
Yeah.
That's it.
Virtual desk that now the problem with Vr,
when you look at that,
the problem with Vr,
like people looking at it on the Internet
is it you cannot convey how fucking
cool it looks from looking at it that way.
Like it is suddenly there's this
massive thing in front of you.
The space look real.
What the space will grill.
Um,
it,
it looks real enough pretty.
I wouldn't say that.
I mean,
I wouldn't say really realistic.
I think there are probably some,
there's got to be by now some three
60 videos that are actually from that,
from Hubble.
But it looks good enough
where you're like,
this is fucking awesome.
Incredible.
Well.
What's the benefit of like they're
just watching you play a video game.
What's the benefit and playing a video
game on a screen in a virtual world
instead of playing the video
game in the virtual world?
Well,
I think,
but honestly in that case,
I don't know,
like I've,
I started a game up in
there and just like,
fuck this,
but do you hear what you
see what I'm saying here?
Because like he's clicking
and menus and stuff.
He's using it like a computer.
Yeah.
I think it's a,
I don't know if the benefit is
the right thing to look for there.
It's just,
it's just bad ass to like suddenly be
completely immersed in a new environment
doing like whatever the work is that you
want to do that with virtual desktop.
I just use it to watch documentaries
about bleeding,
but what I'm thinking is like,
would you rather like,
okay,
like they're perfect example.
You're looking at a screen,
right?
Yeah.
Clearly a floating screen if you
watch jaws and that floating screen,
that would not be as good as if you were
sitting in your living on when you're
looking down,
you were on the boat with Roy Scheider.
Well he was like,
we're gonna need a bigger one.
Oh mean like if there was like a VR jaws,
yes.
Oh yeah,
that'd be fucking cool.
It just doesn't exist yet.
Right.
But that's what I'm saying,
like that's going to happen.
Right?
Of course.
Yeah,
that'll definitely happen for sure.
No question.
And when they do things like that,
like will you be able to enjoy
other things in that world?
Like will you be able
to go into that world?
Like here we're in the Swiss Alps,
where the fuck we are in a fake world?
Would you be able to go to this
place and put on a an an a,
a podcast?
Like would you be able to
like look down at your phone,
find the Duncan Trussell family hour and
start streaming it live on your phone
while you're skiing down the
side of this virtual hill?
Be able to do.
There's,
you could already do,
you could already do that.
Yeah.
Look,
I mean,
look man,
this is like Rick and Morty is video
game is in Vr is accepting that you're in
VR and they're there.
Yeah.
There's like there's a,
there's all kinds of shit
you could do in there.
Like for example,
man,
there's a,
um,
in one of these games called
fantastic contraption,
which is one of the most site dude show,
split reality,
fantastic contraption.
If you looked at this where people have
managed to put up a green screen so that
and interpolate the two videos.
So it looks like you're
actually in the game.
That's the clothes show.
That fantastic contraption is this.
Everything in there is
fucking psychedelic.
But check this out.
When you see people in the,
in the reality itself,
yeah.
There you go.
Whoa.
Watch what he does.
So this guy's walking around.
This is what he's seeing.
So what we're looking at and where we,
he seen does this gonna
we're gonna kicked off.
Use Youtube for this.
You don't need the audio.
Don't know audio please.
I'm worried.
So this guy's moving around
and while he's moving around,
he's doing a bunch of stuff.
He's got a battery on this one though,
for sure.
There's like,
well it takes to explain to the people
that are listening what we're saying.
Oh yeah,
you're just seeing like
in fantastic contraption.
What is that?
What is fantastic contraption?
You're in this like weird putting green
and you'd have to build these amazing
devices to um,
Eh,
the way,
unfortunately these videos,
you're not seeing the guy
actually form the shit.
Like watch this.
What am I watching?
Dunkin people are listening.
Uh,
sorry.
You're seeing,
look at this.
Look at this.
You have to stretch out these like tubes
to build this weird device that you
like then automates itself to try to,
I mean,
honest to God,
talking about it,
you feel like a fucking,
you're listening to an eight year old
talk about a drawing that they made.
Like what?
What are you talking about?
It's impossible to convey.
It's a game and it's a game
where this guy is moving.
He's got devices in his hand and then
devices move things in the virtual world.
He's holding onto these
two like a controllers.
But this is not a good,
if you look up car doesn't matter.
It's pretty fucking fucking cool.
Yeah.
You'll see it on Friday.
I'll show you.
I've got us and what we
need to talk about his porn.
What's that like Duncan?
What's it like in this world?
What's it like?
So,
um,
I mean it's like I'll tell you
something even better than porn man.
Um,
here's what's really cool about VR
that I don't think a lot of people have
caught onto.
Maybe a few of them have.
Cause the porn of course is amazing.
It is.
If anything is going to drive VR
and I hope everything drives Vr,
it's going to be the fucking porn because
the porn that is shot for Vr is very,
very close to like experiencing
having sex with someone,
obviously minus the body,
right?
There's nobody there.
But it's amazing and it's going to cause
a lot of great and hilarious problems.
And I'm excited to hear the outrage that
comes from the world when people start
realizing that every single person on
earth now has access not just to in a
voyeuristic way witnessing,
uh,
Ooh,
that,
that I'm telling you man,
that is,
that's
this girl's acids and sane and
so she's right in front of you,
but this is,
they're not doing a good job
with us cause it's got to,
oh,
that's just how it,
yeah,
you,
you have to use virtual desktop to
bring those two things together.
Like the porn that you download
is broken up and stereoscopic.
So the VR goggles bring it together
to kill you.
You have to get specific programs
that are designed for this,
right?
Yeah.
Like a,
yeah,
just Google search reddit.
How not to watch VR porn
guys that are watching it.
Like we're watching this guy who
is sitting on his bed and like,
he's looks like he's doing everything
to keep from coming in his pants.
He's lab like,
I don't ever watch porn like that.
There's like sheer joy and
him watching that porn,
like what you're talking
about is something that's
very different than watching
a two dimensional screen.
It's,
it's as different as sax and
watching a two dimensional screen,
except there's no body there.
I mean,
you are in,
you look,
or you can look around,
you can like,
you know,
like for example,
let's say there was a,
and by the way,
I'm not doing this shit.
A friend of mine watches it,
but let's say,
let's say that there was a,
um,
uh,
in a,
in a VR porn experience,
there's a girl,
he's giving you a blow job while another
girl is shoving her pussy in your face.
You can actually look
up and see her pussy,
not her pussy.
You can look around
her pussy and see that,
see your face looking down at you,
just like it was really happening.
So that's Vr porn.
That's what it's,
you can look at her pussy and then you
can go back to the other girls talking.
Your Dick,
you give,
you can move anywhere.
You could stare at her
feet if you're a Weirdo
or not,
if you just were a fan of feet
either way,
either way.
Either way.
It's,
it's,
and it's a game changer.
It's a game changer,
man.
It's a game changer and it's one of
the many freedoms the virtual reality's
offering people.
It's like you are saying,
who wants to,
you know,
like even just watching a movie in
two D in your virtual reality room,
it's pretty awesome.
Maybe you don't have
the greatest apartment,
right?
But you put on VR goggles and suddenly
your apartment has transformed into a,
into a massive,
beautiful space.
And the HTC vive,
it comes with like Vr home and
there's two different versions.
But when you go into this space,
you feel that same sense of expansiveness
that you get from being in a big
space.
It's,
your body's still like,
feels like it's,
you know,
you're in a,
you still feel that weird sense of
freedom that you feel when you're in a big
space and you're not there.
It's beautiful,
man.
It's like one of the most liberating,
incredible technologies.
I think that a lot,
some people are giving it a little bit
of a hard time right now because they see
the game from Youtube and they
think those graphics look like Shit.
But let me tell you,
man,
do Minecraft and Vr like I,
they,
I did Minecraft in Vr.
I play my graft at VR regularly now.
But you do Minecraft and Vr and when
suddenly you're perched on the edge of a
cliff looking down on some
hyper colored underground river,
your body initially reacts in the same
way or reacts to being at the edge of a
real cliff.
Your balance gets weird.
You're like,
fuck,
fuck.
It's that real.
That's the vive.
The HTC vive is in fucking saying,
Jesus,
I can't wait to show you man.
It's like,
it just works.
It doesn't,
it doesn't mess up.
Like anytime I want to now I can go.
Like I've,
I've made a room in my house where now
I can just put on these goggles and I'm
instantly in.
Oh fucking,
there's a game called Hover junkers,
which is so fun.
So you,
um,
you,
you could,
you could probably pull it up.
You ride around like it knows how big
the spaces that what's called your place
space that knows how big it is.
So you're riding in a craft in this place,
space shooting weapons at people
flying around in these other things.
Yeah.
It's so you could like,
you could all go in your
garage and you could,
uh,
the garage would become the environment
where you're playing your game.
Oh yeah.
Man,
you're not in your garage anymore.
You're flying around in that
fucking thing shooting at people,
which means you actually
have to be good at shooting.
Like you have to be able to aim,
this isn't like pressing buttons.
Like you need to know how to
fire at least at some Sunday.
What are you holding
you holding a fake gun?
No,
you're holding these controllers
that feel exactly like a fucking,
they feel very close to a gun
and it's got haptic technology.
So when you're shooting,
it's,
I wonder if this would actually
teach you how to shoot better.
They have a,
they have a great archery program.
Is,
is it making your art tree better?
Uh,
it's making me not do
archery because just do it.
It's way easier.
Are you good at it?
Are you good at this archery?
Yeah,
it me doing real archery jet definitely
translated into me playing look up the,
I'm sorry to keep asking
you to look up stuff.
Jamie.
Look up,
uh,
archery.
The lab VR.
This is one of my
favorite archery programs.
They also have a VR boxing,
which I haven't tried yet,
but which I'm excited about because
that seems like you could really train
people to learn how to box.
Let's see.
I'm just,
I don't know if this is,
yeah,
that's,
that's a different archery program
than the one that look up the lab.
Ah,
fuck.
It's,
it's valve look up valve archery.
Vr.
Now there is,
yeah.
This one's a really fucking fun man.
Yeah,
this one is fucking cool.
You just shoot it.
These little guys who were
trying to infiltrate your,
oh,
so you're shooting at things.
Yeah.
And it's so game.
My God.
And you are you pulling a bow back?
Like,
what are you doing in your head?
So you have two controllers,
you're pulling them back.
There's haptics,
so it vibrates according to this,
the tension of the bow string.
And then when you want an Arrow,
you're reaching behind your back and
pulling it from behind your back.is nuts,
man.
Yeah,
it's so fun.
I wonder if it actually could
help your archery skill for sure.
The only problem is it's really
weird because you get used to like,
um,
it's different because
you use a compound bow,
but you know,
you get,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of same.
You get used to like,
I have a place on my cheek
where I put my point.
The anchor point changes cause
the goggles right up here.
So you have to get new anchor point.
But it's still pretty fucking fun.
I mean,
how often you get to shoot at things
in and like an archery range like this?
Yeah,
this is wild.
And I wonder,
that means they should definitely be
able to do something like this for a like
compound balls.
Oh yeah,
definitely go deer hunting with it.
There's another archery program
that you can get on steam.
That looks pretty cool.
Uh,
I can't remember the name of it though,
but it looks a little bit more,
I guess,
realistic.
Well,
they have an archery program.
See if he could find his archery program
where you shoot at us a virtual screen.
You actually shoot a real bow at uh,
these images on a screen and this,
uh,
like you,
you go to like in front of like a giant
movie theater type thing and you stand
in front of this thing and
these animals walked by.
Oh,
that's cool.
And they run from you and they hide and
you got to sneak up on them and shoot
arrows at them.
I mean,
I'm sure this will be translated into VR.
And I'll tell you,
Joe,
if I was,
if I were a young man,
I would be developing shit for Vr.
Right?
Developing.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
It's not a developer.
I would,
there's so many ideas that you will
have when you try these goggles on where
you're going to be like,
this.
Ha,
this needs to exist in the world.
Get this shit developed man,
because it's going to like,
there's so many things that once
you experience it where like,
oh,
someone needs to build this.
Someone like for example,
a fucking boxing game,
he's nodding in the,
in the one hour,
I think I got a demonstration of it.
I was just sitting there asking the guy,
so what about when we're,
someone gets a hold of this and they
start thinking about doing this thing and
what about when rockstar gets it and then
they start thinking about making grand
theft auto this way.
It's like,
yes,
you're exactly,
your brain just take,
well,
fallout is coming for the vive,
which is going to be pretty fucking cool.
But dude for the,
and they have like a a boxing program
that looks like it's still in development,
but a fucking a real boxing
program because it tracks
the controllers perfectly
in real time.
So you could actually learn how to box.
Yes,
someone needs to build a real,
not only learn how to box,
but you could train with the great
boxers like you could throw kicks to.
Well,
you would have to have
something on your foot.
You'd have to have another edition.
It was like that could
be done boots right?
Easily man.
Easily kind of sneakers.
You get a great fucking workout too.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Remember when people were
doing dance dance revolution,
they lost tons of weight.
Yeah,
there was a huge thing a lot of guys lost
and gals lost a ton of weight off that
dance dance revolution again,
cause it was so fun to do.
Well,
that's what's funny about Vr is that
right now when people think of a video
Gamer,
they don't,
you're not going to hear someone say,
oh they are lean and Tan
and they like her deck.
They have such dexterity.
But now when you think of
someone who's great at Vr,
they're gonna.
You gotta be in fucking jail.
There's the box and program.
I'm going to download it.
The creators of this or seem
like they're super cool.
I think I could get a
good workout with this.
They have VR pool top.
Good.
Well I don't want that pools for real.
But see,
the thing about this is this is something
that you could do on your own and get
a workout in.
What I,
what I find interesting about this too
is you could tune a dude up and you don't
feel bad about it right now.
What you need to do eventually is they're
going to have something that looks
like this,
but it's a robot.
Like both things.
Like you have an a thing
that you can actually hit.
Well now you could just,
you could already,
I'm sure there's a way that
you could hang a bag and um,
cause like,
okay,
so when I,
um,
when I'm talking about southern,
the hits back,
well,
yeah,
that's,
that,
that's going to be something that
it doesn't have to have a lot of power.
They could have like a really mushy
arm and it knows how to move the way,
the way you move,
like it's actually a
throwing punches at you.
So if it hits you,
it's not hurting you.
You know what that could be,
man,
it could be like a haptic face mask
that registers the punch and vibrates so
that you could feel it,
you know,
and,
and wherever it hits you.
But it also could be like some sort of
a robot that has inflatable arms and the
inflatable arms move with the program.
So as you're looking at
Apollo creed in front of you,
when he snaps his jab out at you pop,
he is,
he's throwing this like spongy,
almost like a inflatable raft balloon arm.
You know,
like when you're little kids.
Yeah.
Inflatable balloon toys.
Like that.
Like it's not gonna hurt you at all.
It's just going to touch your face.
It'd be fucking incredible.
And,
and what's in,
what you're going to see,
man,
is people are going to get
really good at this shit.
Like if you're good at shooting and VR
minus like the half to the gun and the
real kick of whatever gun in the real
world are you using [inaudible] it's going
to translate.
Okay.